fear factor is back and only et is on
the set of the MTV reboot and as I found
out from host Ludacris himself they're
taking an epic new spin on an old
classic these challenges are extremely
crazy what's just being on television is
this is real but yes it's dangerous very
dangerous
shut up here today this is really like
something that would happen in the movie
they're taking a car they're gunning the
gas and they're trying to get over this
ramp while there's explosions and things
going on at the same time try to flip
the car over and get it to slide on its
roof as far as it can possibly go so
when I say it's dangerous it's extremely
dangerous
the original it had that had the crazy
stunts but it also is kind of gross you
know like our folks eating bull
testicles in this one I would say
they're eaten bull testicles however
there are some things that are similar
to you know the old ones and all praise
do man it still has the same theme same
DNA but we've changed things around we
made it new and it's 14 the new Fear
Factor scared up nearly 1 million total
viewers making it MTV's highest-rated
premiere in two years 3 2 1 go what was
it about this show and the reboot that
made you say yes I'm gonna drink the
junkie myself what better way to watch
on television than to see people doing
this firsthand a lot of individuals
during this show are here to overcome
their fear and you will be surprised how
many people just need a little push in a
little motivation from someone that they
admire and respect so that's what I'm
doing for each and every contestant
that's on the fence about certain things
letting them know they can do it life is
all about overcoming your fear
so tackle them head on Luda you do
everything you can do anything but I
want to know what is your greatest fear
in life and how do you overcome it being
in open water and having something brush
up against your leg and you don't know
what the hell it is that scares me just
thinking about really I don't like that
we never went swimming other kids
Melo's know but I watched all of the
jaws movies and that's probably the
reason I don't like it
you
[Music]